ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะวัน
อังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ห้าเดือน
อะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะดีผช
2565 หม้อ
2565 นักเรียนอะไรอยู่นะคะ
ปีกค่ะสไตส์เท่าไหร่คะดีขอศ.
2022 ค่ะโอเคนะสามสองหนึ่งปีคศ 2 โทร 0
2225 ใส่ค่ะให้ผู้หญิงทำไมดิ
กิโลกตามเฉยๆซ้ายขวา
โยกโยกซ้ายโยกขวา
โอเค
ครูหญิงคะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงตอนนี้เวลา 4
โมง
2 นาทีค่ะ
04:02
มีหลายนักเรียนกี่คนคะนี่นะเรียน 1  2  3
4  4  5  5  6  7  8  9  10  11 คนค่ะ 11
คน
เย้
ถ่ายทำวันนี้ครูหญิงมีอะไรขอให้วันนี้ครู
หญิงมี
รูปให้ครูเอ๋ดูให้ดูนะนักเรียนดูมั้ยดู
นักเรียนดูครูเอ๋ดูนักเรียนถามได้ไหมคะ
ไม่ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋ถามได้อ่อนนักเรียนถามไม่
ได้ครูเองครับโอเค
แต่กูเอถาม
นักเรียนถามภาษาอังกฤษได้ไหมได้นักเรียน
ยกมือถามภาษาอังกฤษโอเคนักเรียนขามภาษา
ญี่ปุ่นอน
โอ่งโอเคไหมให้ครูเอ๋เข้าใจไหมคะเข้าใจ
นิดหน่อยนักเรียนก็แอ็กชันถามแล้วก็แบบ
Action ครูก็เข้าใจโอเคค่ะ
งั้นเนี่ยนักเรียนถามเป็นภาษาญี่ปุ่นโอเค
ภาษาอังกฤษโอเคนะคะแต่นักเรียนใหม่พูด
ภาษาไทยใส่ค่ะนักเรียนต้องมีหูใช่ไหมคะ
หูเนี่ยแล้วก็ฟัง
ฟังฟังเข้าใจ
ดีไม่เข้าใจไม่เข้าใจอะไรหรอโอเคไหมตัว
เอง
ไม่เป็นไรฟังครั้งที่ 2 ฟังครั้งที่ 3
ฟังครั้งที่ 4
เข้าใจค่ะ
โอเควันนี้มีรูปใช่ไหมคะชายรู๋ถามนะถ้า
นักเรียนไม่ต้องถามค่ะเดี๋ยวครูหญิง Share
screen ขาข้า
เห็นหรือยังคะเห็นค่ะ
อู้ผู้หญิงค่าขาผู้หญิงถามครูเอ๋ถามผู้
หญิงเนาะ
ตายค่ะคุณทั้งคู่เอกก่อนคู่ a คะอันนี้
เป็นอะไรคะ
กันหล่ำ
การทำปลี
เป็นผักเป็นผักเป็นผักชุดตัดชื่ออะไรคะ
ครูเอ๋ขอโทษค่ะผู้หญิงถามเป็นอะไรคะเป็น
ผักขาอะไรค่ะผักไรรูปนี้ชื่ออะไรคะครูเอ๋
กะหล่ำปลีโหกะหล่ำปลีครูเอ๋กะหล่ำปลี
เนี่ยสีอะไรเนี่ยเธออย่าดู
4 สี
สีเขียว
แล้วก็สีขาว
ตรงนี้สีเขียวตรงนี้สีขาวค่ะใช่มีครูเอ๋
คะอ่ะค่ะ
ครูเอ๋
กินกะหล่ำปลีไหมคะกินค่ะครูหญิงกินกะหล่ำ
ปลีไหม
อินคา
ครูเอ๋เอ๋กินกะหล่ำปลีกินค่าครูเอ๋ชอบไหม
คะครูเอกชอบกะหล่ำปลี
นักเรียนแล้วคะกินไหม
ชอบไหม
ยินโอ้นักเรียนบ่ออกกิน
ชอบไหมคะอ๋อ
แต่บางคนชอบบางคนไม่ชอบนะคะ
ครูหญิงนะคะชอบกินกะหล่ำปลีไหมคะ
คอบมากค่ะหมอก็ผู้หญิงชอบกินกะหล่ำปลีมาก
ฮือ
ครูเอ๋
เชิญค่ะเมื่อกี้ก็เลยค่ะผู้หญิงจะถามอะไร
ฮะผู้หญิงก็ถามว่าเวลาครูเอ๋กินกะหล่ำปลี
เนี่ยกะหล่ำปลีมีกลิ่นไหมคะ
ดมว่ะดมต้องมีจมูกจมูกรเมี่กะลัมปีมี
กลิ่นนี้เป็นยังไง
ขอ
คะคู่เอกคิด
ขอมโหลอ๊อฟรูหญิงคิดว่า
มีกลิ่นกะหล่ำปลีของหรือเหม็นผู้หญิงคิด
หอมค่ะครูเอ๋
หอมนะคะ
อร่อยอร่อยอ่ะผัดต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
เอาไป
ผักในรูปนี้ชื่ออะไรคะครูเอ๋ดูก่อนนะคะ
ได้ค่ะอ๋อ
ผักกาดขาว
งูผัดกาดขาวสีอะไรคะผักกาดขาวมีสีเขียว
ตีขาว
เหมือนกะหล่ำปลี
มีสีเขียวแล้วก็สีขาวค่ะครูเอ๋กินผักกาด
ขาวไหมคะจินค่ะน้อชอบไหมคะ
ถ้าชอบมากโห
ครูหญิงล่ะคะกินผักกาดขาวไหมคะ in ค่ะชอบ
ไหมคะ
ชอบมากค่ะ
คู๋ชอบมากครูหญิง
ชอบมากค่ะมา
มา
เอกชอบมากเท่านี้ค่ะนักเรียนน่ะนะเรียน
กินผักกาดขาวไหมคะอ๋อนักเรียนพยักหน้าค่ะ
ครูหญิงนักเรียนทุกคนกินผักกาดขาวแล้ว
นักเรียนชอบไหม
นักเรียนนักเรียนกำลังคิดข้อ
แต่ไม่เป็นไร comment นะใช่ชอบไม่ชอบโอเค
ตอนนี้นักเลยบอกก่อนคิดก่อน
อ่าๆๆ
ตายนักเรียนชอบไม่ชอบกินผักกอล์ฟคอมเม้น
ข้างล่างนะคะได้โอเคต่อไปมีไหมคะนี่ค่ะ
โอ๊ะโอครูเอ๋คะในรูปนี้ถักชื่ออะไรคะ
ผักคะน้า
คะน้าสีอะไรคะครูเอ๋
เขียวแล้วก็สีเขียวแล้วก็สีเขียวโอ้โหหาง
หมดสีเขียวสีเขียวค่ะ
พี่เอ๋กินผัดคะน้าไหมคะคู๋ in ผักคะน้า
หมู
ผู้หญิงกินผักคะน้าไหมคะ
กินค่ะกิน
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ชอบไหมคะผักคะน้าคู่เอ๋
แจง
ไปชอบกูอยู่ที่นี่ลูกเกดเฮ้ยกินโอเคไม่
กินโอเคนี้ครูเอ๋นะคะ
อันนี้ชอบไม่ชอบ
ชอบเป็นเฉยๆโอเคเฉยๆเย้ไป 2 รอบ
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงอ่ะคะชอบกินผักคะน้ามะอยู่
ในสอบกิน
ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบกินผักคะน้า
คู๋ก็เฉยๆค่ะเคยเฉยๆเนาะว่า
ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ขอเฉยๆไปเร็วๆไปใช่ๆไม่ชอบ
ไป
ผัดในรูปนี้ชื่ออะไรคะครูเอ๋
กวางตุ้งใช่ไหมคะไทยค่า
สีอะไรคะครูเอ๋วางตุ้ง
มีสีเขียวแล้วก็สีเหลืองอ่ะน้อสีเขียว
เนี่ยเรียกว่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋ใบกวางตุ้งอ้าว
แล้วสีเหลืองอ่ะคะอันนี้อะไรคะดอก
กวางตุ้ง
ดอกดอกค่ะอ่ะว่าแล้วต้องนี้นะคะคู๋เรียก
อะไรคะต้นกว่าตุงโห
ครูเอ๋กินกวางตุ้งกินผัดกวางตุ้งไหมคะคู๋
กินผักกวางตุ้งค่ะผู้หญิงกินผักกวางตุ้ง
ไหมคะกินค่ะ
ครูเอ๋กินครูเอ๋ท่อผัดกวางตุ้งไหมคะคู่
เอกชอบผักวางตุ้งมากเท่านี้มากโอ้โห
ครูเอกครูเอ๋ครูเอชอบตรงไหนชอบใบชอบดอกรถ
ชอบต้น
ข้าวโงดเลยขอกูแอบชอบทางหมดเลยตัวเองชอบ
ผักวางตุ้งทั้งหมดชอบกินนะถ้าครูผู้หญิง
ถ้าชอบกินผักกวางตุ้งไหมคะชอบกินค่ะสอบ
กินผู้หญิงชอบตรงไหนคะผู้หญิงชอบ
หมวกใหม่หาไม่รู้
ผู้หญิงชอบกินใบหน้าๆไปอ่ะ
เวลาครูเอ๋กับผู้หญิงกินผักกวางตุ้งด้วย
กันกูเอกก็ต้องเอาใบไปครูเอ๋ชอบต้นชอบ
กล้ามทุนถ้าการมาเอาต้นมา
สายผู้หญิงไม่ใบหญิงไม่
ให้ครูเอ๋ค่ะเอ๋แชร์
ไทดีใจดีดีดีนะคะผู้หญิงไม่ชอบกินต้น
ชอบครั้งหมดค่ะหนูต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ไปอ่ะ
มีอะไรคะครูโอ๋น่าจะชอบนะคะเนี่ย
วงนา
[เพลง]
ถ้าชอบผักบุ้งไหมคะ
อะไรพวกเนี้ย
ธรรมดาเฉยๆเฉยๆชอบมากชอบผู้หญิงเฉยเฉย
โอเคครูหญิงครูเอ๋เอ๋กินผู้หญิงให้ครูเอ๋
โอ๊ยครูเองคู๋เห็นแล้วหิวอยากกินไม่ได้
ค่ะเราต้องไปผัดต่อไปค่ะครูเองเสียงไปไหน
พี่เอ๋ไม่ได้ยินกูยังไม่ได้ยินเหรอคะกู
อีก
กลับมาแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงขายตัว a หา
ผู้หญิง
มาแล้วมาแล้วอ่ะไปมาพักต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋โอ๋
อันนี้เป็นผักใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะค่า
อะไรคะครูพี่เก๋ค่ะหาก
กระเฉดหนูครูเอ๋ผัดกระเฉดกินตรงไหน
ผัดกระเฉดกินโอ๋เดี๋ยวนะผู้หญิงกินตรงยอด
นะคะพี่เอกขอวาดหน่อยเวลาดูไม่เข้าใจตรง
ไหนกินได้กินได้หมดเลยกูหญิงกูใบแต่ๆสี
ขาวเนี่ยสีขาวต้องเนี้ยอ้ะต้อง
รูดรูดรูดออกก็ขอ
ต้องเอาสีขาวๆออกไปค่ะแล้วเป็นแบบนี้เหรอ
คะใช่ๆอ่า
มีเป็นสีขาวๆเราเรียกว่านมนะนมผักกระเฉด
เอาออกทั่วไปและอันนี้เหรอคะครูเอ๋นมผัก
กระเฉดค่ะใช่แล้วก็ออกไปงวดนี้ไม่มีเหตุ
รู้เองกินผักกระเฉดไหมคะกินค่ะ
ฮอบไหมคะ
ชอบเมื่อกี้เมื่อกี้ผักบุ้งชอบมากใช่ไหม
คะค่ะตัดก็เสร็จชอบ
มากสองรอบผลสอบมากกว่าผักบุ้งครูเองมาก
กว่าค่ะ
ถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยไม่รู้นี่ค่ะผัดกระเฉดทำ
อะไรคะเมนูนี้ผัด
ผัดผักกระเฉด
นิทานนักเรียนเคยเห็น
โอเคๆครูเอ๋หิวต้องเปลี่ยนค่ะอากูเอ nuke
อ่อนดู
กลืน
ปืนเราลาย
ครูหิงค์กินผักเกษตรไหมคะกินค่ะผู้หญิง
ชอบผัดเกษตรไหมคะ
เฉยๆเฉยเฉยๆๆผู้หญิงดูนักเรียนเซ็นัก
เรียนกินผักกระเศษไหมคะนักเรียนบอก
ไม่รู้ไม่รู้จักนักเรียนไม่รู้จักเธอ
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะมากินนะไม่
โอเคผู้หญิงอยู่ที่นี่กูอื่นดูไม่ได้ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เราต้องเปลี่ยนค่ะนักเรียนอยากรู้
จักผักในประเทศไทยของเคมั้ยเปลี่ยน
อะไรอันนี้คะอันนี้ผักอะไรคะครูเอ๋เอ่อ
อ่า
เอาคนไทยพูดหรือฝรั่งพูดคนไทยพูดเหมือน
ปวยเล้งป่ะ
เร่งฝรั่งสวยแรงภาษาจีนไปเน้นฝรั่งไป
ถึงเป็นปวยเล้งของฝรั่งไม่ใช่ของคนไร
อะไรผักโขมเหรอคะไอ้ค่ะครูเอ๋ที่เขาเก่ง
ผักนะผักโขมแต่มีผักโขมหลายๆอย่างค่ะ
อันนี้ครูเอ๋น่ะเป็นไทยจีนเรียกปวยเล้ง
เค้าพูดเอ๋ๆเป็นป่วยเล้งอ่าแบบ 5 เป็น
อะไรนะเป็นคนไทยพูดผักโขมตอนขอหอมผักโขม
กินเป็นสลัดได้ครูเอ๋กินผักโขมไหมคะกิน
ค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะ
โอเคอ๋อเฉยๆเฉยเฉยๆ
ผู้หญิงกินผักโขมไหมคะ in ค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะ
ชอบค่ะ
ตอบมีใบตอบพ่อออกนิ่ม
ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ถามนะคะเรียน
เอาไม่ถามเรียนไม่ถามนักเรียนพยักหน้าใส
หน้าโอเค
low  Air ครับอะไรคะรหัสในรูปนี้เรียก
ว่าอะไรคะต่ำ 1 ค่ะ
ตำลึงเนาะผัดคนไทยอัดไทยชื่อตามมาเลยมา
ช่วยเอ๋กินตำลึงไหมคะกินค่ะงงกินใบแล้วก็
ตรงนี้เรียกอะไรคะครูเอ๋ยอดค่ะยอดยอดนะ
กรุ๊ป A กินทางหมดกินทั้งหมดค่ะพอชอบไหม
คะ
ชอบค่ะอ๋อตี
ผักกระเฉดชอบ
มากผักบุ้งชอบมากผักตำลึงชอบมากโห้ครูเอ๋
ชอบผักคนไทยว่าชอบผัดไทยไป
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้อ้ะต้องไปผักต่อไปค่ะนัก
เรียนจะได้รู้จักผู้หญิงกินไหมกินค่ะชอบ
ไหมคะโชว์รูปค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงก็ชอบตำลึง
นี้นะคะตายต่อไปต่อไปค่ะผัดในรูปเรียกว่า
อะไรคะครูเอ๋ถั่วฝักยาวถั่ว
สีเขียวใช่หาดทรายของตัวเองครูเอ๋กินไหม
คะกินค่ะก็ชอบไหมคะอ่า
ชอบ
ชอบชอบ
โอเค
จะชอบนะแต่ชอบสอบไม่ออกเฉยๆชอบแต่ไม่ใช่
มึงรอบค่ะ
ผู้หญิงนะคะกินถั่วฝักยาวไหมกินค่ะผู้
หญิงชอบถั่วฝักยาวไหมคะ
เฉยๆค่ะเฉยๆนะคะเฉยๆมีอีกไหมคะมีอีกไหมคะ
ดีค่ะพี่เก๋โอโอ้วผัดในรูปเรียกว่าอะไรคะ
อ่ะอ่า
อะไรนะ
ขึ้นฉ่าย
ขึ้นฉ่ายนักครูเอ๋เอ๋กินขึ้นฉ่ายไหมคะกู
เองกินขึ้นฉ่ายค่ะค่ะชอบไหมคะชอบมากมีหนู
ชอบกินขึ้นฉ่ายถ้าผู้หญิงกินขึ้นฉ่ายไหม
คะไม่กินค่ะ
โอเคไม่ถาม
กูเอกคิดถามชอบไหมคะคุณหญิงบอกไม่กินกู
เองโอเคไม่ถามไม่กินก็คือไม่ชอบ
ถามไม่ได้
ต่อไปดีกว่าไหมคะครูเอ๋ค่ะต่อไปโอ้วผัด
อะไรคะครูเอ๋กะเพรา
ครูเอ๋เอ๋กินกะเพราไหมคะกูเอกกินกับเพรา
พ่อไหมคะชอบมาก
คุ้ย
ผู้หญิงโห
หายเลยกูเองกินตรงนี้กินได้มั้ยสาเรียก
อะไรคะตรงนี้ดอกจะเพรากินไหมคะเอ่อครูเอ๋
กินแต่คนไทยคนไทยคนไทยคนไทยคนไทยคนไทยมาก
ๆไม่กินเก่งชายค่ะกินที่นี่กินใบให้คุ่
กินนะหาคนไทย
มากๆเลยไม่กินน่ะนี้
ผู้หญิงล่ะคะกินกับเพราไหมอยากกิน
car2 นะชอบช้อป
เวทชอบ
ช้อบชอบมากไงชอบไหมค่ะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
ผัดอะไรคะครูเอ๋ขอรพา
รู๋กินโหระพาไหมคะกินค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะชอบมากค่ะกู
กะเพรากู S ตรงนี้
เรียกว่าอะไรดอกโหระพา
กินไหมคะกินค่ะกินเนาะอ่ากินดอกโคราชพา
กินใบโหระพาอันนี้ค่ะใบโหระพา
ก้านไม่กินผู้
อยากกินโหระพาไหมคะกินค่ะผู้หญิงชอบโขรพา
ไหมคะ
งู
ไม่ไปๆชอบอ่ะเดี๋ยว in แต่ไม่ชอบกินแต๋ม
ไม่ชอบแต่กินสปาเก็ตตี้โหระพากินเป็นแบบ
ไม่กิน
โอเคมากๆใช่
แค่กินเวทย์
โหระพาโหระพาโหระพาโหระพาอบผัดแล้วก็กิน
แล้วก็โหระพากินใช้ kuai ให้ครูหญิงเยอะๆ
ผู้หญิงต้องไม่ต้มคุยมีฟาร์มโหระพาคุณภาพ
ตัวเองใหญ่มาก
ชอบ
ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ผัดอะไรโป้ขาตาระแนค่ะแต่
ละแด่ครูเอ๋กินไหมคะกินข้า
ชอบไหมคะท่อรอบค่ะโห
กูเอกชอบ
สะแนนชอบขอรพาชอบกับเครา
ของ
หมอสะระแหน่หอมค่ะโหราคาหอ
กระเพราหอม
หนู
ตัวเองชอบกลิ่นหอมๆ
[เพลง]
ทำไมผู้หญิงกินสะระแหน่ไหมคะ
อินทาผู้หญิงชอบสะระแหน่ไหมคะ
โอเคอ่าอยู่โคราชพาดีกว่า
เองชอบสะระแหน่ชอบโคราชพาแวะเอาโหระพา
สะระแหน่
แอปเปิ้ล
ผู้หญิงแหละ
อร่อยชอบ
สัตว์ต่อไปค่ะผัดอะไรคะค่ะค่ะชี
รูด์ x กินไหมคะกินค่ะรอกูเอ๋คะใบกินไหม
คะกินค่ะก้าน
กินค่ะราดกินค่ะ
โอ้วครูเอ๋ทั้งหมดค่ะ O กินทั้งใบ
ก้านราดชอบไหมคะ
ชอบมากๆ
the  way ชอบผัดนะคะ
ครูเอกชอบเอามาทำสลัดเอ้าสลัด
ผักชีแย่ค่ะผู้หญิง
กินผักชีไหมคะกินค่ะผู้หญิงชอบผักชีไหมคะ
ชอบค่ะชอบใบ
นางก้านไม่ชอบรากไม่ชอบคู่เองชอบทั้งหมด
เอามา
ตัวเองชอบผักหน่อยค่ะชอบผักชอบค่ะผัด
ต่อไปค่ะบัญชีให้บอกอันนี้อะไรคะครูเอ๋
เอ๋ผัดอะไร
ภาษาไทยนะคะค่ะหักเค้กฝรั่ง
ผักชี of ครูเอ๋รูปนี้ผักชีค่ะรูปนี้ 4G
ฝรั่งอ่ารูปนิรูปนั้นผักชีบางทีพูดผักชี
ไทยอ๋อ
แบบพูดผักชีโอเค
ดีนะคะบัดซีโอเคอันนี้ผักชีฝรั่งค่ะครู
เอ๋เอ๋กินไหมคะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงบางคนพูดผัก
ชีใบเรื่อยขอ
มี 2 ชื่อ
ไม่เรื่อยแบบนี้หรอๆ
มาที่เลื่อยไม้หอมผักชีใบเลื่อยเลยหรือ
ผักชีฝรั่งโอเคค่ะครูเอ๋กินไหมคะกินค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะชอบมาก
ช่วยคุยชอบผ่านกลิ่นเหม็นหอ
M หอ
หนังโป๊โอเคค่ะผู้หญิงคิด
แมนแหมนตัวเอกคิดหอบเว้กินกินกินกินมากๆ
ผู้หญิงกินไหมคะ
กิน
นิดหน่อยหน่อยยชอบกินมากๆไงชอบไปชอบนะกิน
ได้แต่ไม่ชอบในสอบค่ะรีบแท็กซี่อีก 1 อัน
นี้ฉัน
คุณเอมี่เหรอคะลาเต้
ตอนนั้น
เอาอันไหนดี
นี่ค่ะครูครูเอ๋แล้วผักอันนี้มันเรียกว่า
อะไรคะภาษาไทยใช่ไหมคะค่ะภาษาไทยผัก
เล่นเพลงอีลาวหนูเห
นะคะก็คือเห็นมีที่บ้านครูเอ๋ชอบไหมคะเขต
Game  in ตัวเอกกินได้หรอไม่ต้องทำอาหาร
หรอเก๋เด็ดแล้วก็กินเลย
เขียว
ขอ
เหม็น
แม้นของเหม็น
ผู้หญิงมาเฟียนะผู้หญิงไม่ชอบไม่กิน
ผู้หญิงโกรธครูเอ๋ไหมคะรู้เห็นชอบมาก f
ทำอาหารโอเองผักชีลาว
แม้ทั้งคู๋ไม่เล่นเพลง
เอ็ไปกิน
ถ้าที่รักอ่ะกูแอบสีดำมามากค่ะได้สาวจริง
ๆมีผักอีกมากๆค่ะแต่วันนี้หมดเวลาแล้ว
เวลาและชายค่ะจบด้วยผักชีลาวครูเอ๋ชีลาว
ผักชีลาวอีลาวเออดีค่ะดูใกล้ๆเนาะเห็นไหม
ฟ้าเหมือนๆดีว่ะเนาะของฝรั่งดีดิว 8 อ่า
ของไทยก็ผักชีลาว
แต่บางคิดว่าคนไทยแบบผู้หญิงเนี่ยนะคะไม่
ไม่กินไม่ชอบตัวเองชอบ
วันนี้ให้ครูเอ๋ไปกินผักชีนะผักชีลาวนะคะ
ผู้หญิงกับครูก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้าอ้าบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียน